ähm in der corona-krise wurden meiner
Meinung nach Verbrechen begangen
teilweise gegen die Menschlichkeit und
die Verursacher dieser Verbrechen müssen
vor Gericht gestellt werden die das
fokussiert auf den Lockdown auf die
covid-impfkampagne und den Ursprung des
Virus andere Länder beginnen diese
Debatte sie fangen an darüber zu
diskutieren über die Unsinnigkeit des
lockdowns über die Verantwortlichkeiten
wie Großbritannien die Premierministerin
von Alberta in Kanada entschuldigt sich
für
impfdiskriminierung und will sie per
Gesetz verbieten des Supreme Court in
New York
rehabilitiert Polizeibeamte und
Feuerwehrleute die standhaft geblieben
sind sich nicht haben impfen lassen und
ortet jetzt an dass die
wiedereingestellt werden und der Lohn
auch ausgezahlt wird also in anderen
Ländern ist die Debatte vor den gangeln
nur wir halten die Leute weiterhin im
waren
betreiben angstpropaganda ohne Ende in
denen zum Beispiel auch
behauptet wird dass kovid nach wie vor
die Krankenhäuser belastet das stimmt
nicht seit Omegon gibt es quasi keine
echten covid-kranken mehr das sagen alle
Lungenärzte zum Beispiel Thomas vossa
auch der Präsident der pneumologischen
Kliniken das führt so weit dass wir
heute
herztote Krebs tote mit einem PCR-Test
um etikettieren völlig unwürdig um
Abrechnungssysteme zu optimieren die
fließen dann heute in die in die
sterbetal Statistik ein und heute haben
wir in Deutschland den zehnten Teil
aller weltweiten kovi tote also haben
wir hier eine killervariante die vor der
Grenze halten
kann also eigentlich werden wir von
unserer Politik komplett an der Nase
rumgeführt und Karl Lauterbach erzählt
total ein Schwachsinn eigentlich gibt es
viel zu viele Intensivbetten und Corona
ist eigentlich
extra Thema aber das ist definitiv so
dass die kovid-epidemie seit Omegon
vorbei ist und wir haben schon relativ
nicht nur mein meinem eigenen
Freundeskreis schaue da sehe ich schon
sehr sehr viele Menschen die sich immer
noch mit Kurve anstecken und die
teilweise auch wirklich schwere Verläufe
ganz seltsamerweise ging die Inzidenz
der kurveterkrankungen mit der
Impfkampagne nach oben komisch oder aber
jedenfalls fakt ist wir haben den
zehnten Teil aller kurvitoten weltweit
wie kann das sein haben wir eine
killervariante die an der Grenze aufhört
oder haben wir vielleicht die
kielervariante die in Wirklichkeit Karl
Lauterbach heißt wirklich also und jetzt
wird immer noch einer drauf gesetzt
jetzt werden die Kinder und Säuglinge
wird die Impfung freigegeben diese
kurvitimpfung und die haben 0,0 nutzen
und täglich kommen Studien rein die die
Gefährlichkeit dieser Impfung weiter
andeuten wie zum Beispiel sind Basel 800
Mitarbeiter der Kliniken boosterimpfung
5% haben ein erhöhtes Troponin das ist
ein Wert der nur bei einem Herzschaden
hoch geht ich hätte mich jetzt
eigentlich nicht impfen lassen sollen
ich bin mehrfach ich bin dreimal geimpft
ich bin auch zweimal gelesen sagen sie
das hätte ich lieber nicht machen soll
nach einer vernünftigen Abwägung wie
sind der Patien Kater der
Bundesregierung festgelegt ist hätte man
sie informieren müssen erstens über den
Charakter der Zulassung die ist nämlich
bedingt und deswegen experimentell
zweitens hätte man ihn Ihr Risikoprofil
erklären müssen dass gegen Null geht ja
also null ist im übertrieben aber bei
Kindern ist es null sie haben überhaupt
wenig zu befürchten von kurvit aber sie
haben eine Impfung der davon zum
Beispiel empfehlen zu lassen es kommt
auf die Vorerkrankung an das will ich
jetzt hier nicht erfragen wenn in der
Sprechstunde es kann individuellen
Fällen hätte man vielleicht sehr
kontrolliert mit genauen
Vergleichsgruppen für Risikogruppen die
Impfung anwenden können um zu schauen
was passiert und aber dann rechtzeitig
zu merken dass Alarm wir lassen das mal
lieber aber man hat einfach auf die
Bevölkerung losgelassen aber Fakt ist ja
nun auch das bevor es die Impfungen gab
hatten wir unheimlich viele Menschen die
gestorben sind die auf den
Intensivstationen lagen die beatmet
wurden und eben danach nachdem sie
herunterladen
sehr wohl sehr schwer kranke Menschen
so einen Unsinn erzählt da muss ich
ehrlich sagen
es gab damals
so nach zweieinhalb Jahren so emotional
zu argumentieren ohne Zahlen zu bringen
Fakten zu bringen ist einfach belämmt
ich habe Verwandte in dieser Richtung
gehabt
wenn Sie eine epidemiologische Bewertung
einer Krankheit machen können sie nicht
mit Einzel Beispielen kommen ich habe
Patienten die die sterben ich habe
Patienten die krank sind wir haben nicht
nur korvit 19 und es wenn wir einfach
die Fakten sehen wir haben bitte lassen
Sie jetzt die Fakten sagen ja die stehen
auf der Homepage des bundesges
Gesundheitsministerin ich sag's dir weil
jeder Sendung wir hatten eine und nicht
dramatisch an der historische
Unterbelegung der Krankenhäuser und der
inten Aufteilungen und deshalb zwei
Jahren nicht durchgehen
das können Sie nachlesen das ist Fakt
wir hatten ich habe Fakten nachgelesen
und es gab Zeiten wo unsere
Intensivbetten komplett ausgebucht waren
und Menschen die Herzinfarkte oder
ähnliches hatten und einen intensivbett
gebraucht haben keins bekommen haben als
Journalistin nicht gemacht sie müssen
die gesamte so nicht sagen aber das sage
ich ganz sicher sie müssen hier die
Gesamtzahlen sehen und die Gesamtzahlen
sind eindeutig dass er die Leipzig
Analyse gezeigt während ein historische
Unterbelegung und zwar 13% weniger
Patienten warum vorher sich dann
hingestellt und gesagt wir haben ein
riesiges Problem wir haben nichts fragen
die Charité weil sie nämlich nicht die
Zahlen argumentiert ich habe letztes Mal
eigentlich einen Kardiologen von der
Charité hier gehabt
natürlich nein lassen Sie sich mal die
Belegungszahlen geben von 2019 18 20 21
und Sie werden staunen sie werden
staunen die Krankenhäuser haben sich
eine goldene Nase verdient an leeren
Betten und an der Panikmache von
kurvenweg kurvit und jetzt behaupten sie
dass wir es weiterhin viele kurvitote
haben das sind keine Toten und wenn wir
10%
oder eine Intensivbetten da kommen wir
jetzt ja mit ja wir sind durcheinander
ne also da müssen wir einfach Analyse
sagt eindeutig es gab wie immer im
Winter punktuell Überbelastungen aber es
gab immer freie Betten das ist die
Normalität sie können nicht für jede
winterepidemie ausreichend für jedes
lokale Krankenhaus und ein normales
immer wieder was anderes als unterbelegt
wenn man sagt okay nach dem Impfen ist
es wieder auf dem Normalzustand gegangen
oder ist es unterbelegt ist ja noch mal
ein Unterschied ja also die die
Inzidenzen die die die Norm also nicht
krankenhauspflichtigen
Infektion ging es seltsamerweise mit der
Impfung steil nach oben dort bei der
Bundeswehr zum Beispiel und wir hatten
aber de facto keine außergewöhnliche
medizinische Belastung durch Kurve das
ist Fakt das kann ich belegen und es
wird einfach nicht in den Medien
diskutiert vielleicht was falsch ist
ich habe viel schon gehört von Medizin
ja aber nein
Sie können Ihr Buch weiter propagieren
und dann werden
unverschämt
persönlich zu nennen 2018
wir haben keinerlei solide Wissenschaft
betrieben um wirklich mal klare Sicht zu
bekommen auf die Situation und nach
zweieinhalb Jahren haben wir die harten
Daten ich möchte die
wenn sie das nicht so anderen würden sie
sich noch mal impfen lassen oder eher
nicht
nichts da da sagen sie nicht meine
privat
ich würde gerne etwas sagen sehr gerne
ich hatte schon mal vor zwei Jahren das
Vergnügen mit Ihnen zusammen in einem in
der Talk Sendung zu Sessel haben sie mir
unterstellt tatsächlich ich würde Fake
News verbreiten weil nein habe ich nicht
auf die immer Datenbank verwiesen habe
und auch sehr sehr geschafft
ein Wissenschaftler ein Physiker hat mir
auch Fake News unterstellt in der
anderen Sendung weil er geleugnet hat
das ist eine bedingte Zulassung ist nach
nach einer Verordnung die könnte ich
hier auch runterrattern darum geht es
gar nicht was ich hier erlebe ist für
mich echt erstaunlich weil in anderen
Staaten ist die aufklärungssituation
schon längst weiter in Amerika in den
USA in dem Land in dem sie gelebt haben
haben sich einige Bürgerinitiative da
zusammengetan und haben die CDC und die
FDA verklagt und haben es geschafft die
kaiserdokumente des ersten Schadens
Berichts seit Beginn der Impfkampagne
herauszuklagen jetzt ist es so dass die
jede Woche jeden Monat 500 Seiten auf
eine Website hochladen und sich jeder
Mensch die angucken kann und stellen
sich vor ich habe es getan und wissen
Sie was eine der wichtigen
Nebenwirkungen ist neben ganz
schrecklichen Dingen die bei Säuglingen
abgelaufen sind neokaditis und
Thrombosen und Hirnschläge es ist
wirklich grauslich covid 19 ist einer
der Nebenwirkungen steht im Pfizer
Bericht ich glaube februar und die FDA
wusste es das bedeutet das wusste die
amerikanische Regierung und wenn es
Peiser wusste dann gehe ich davon aus
dass wenigstens der Kollege drüben in
Mainz es auch wusste und dann auch das
bundesgesundheit also wir sehen hier
dass der deutschen das eine deutsche
Medien ein ganz harter Aufschlag
bevorsteht wenn sie wieder Wirklichkeit
wirklich mal sich konfrontiert ich
glaube sie mal die hatten Daten sich an
ich kann sie in demonstrieren dann
können anschauen Medizinern haben wir
hier schon viel diskutiert auch in
unserem offensichtlich haben wir hier
zwei Wahrheiten also die eine ist und
eine andere die in der Welt herumläuft
das kann ich so jetzt nicht sagen weil
ich wenn die wenn die wenn die
krankenhausbelegung zweieinhalb Jahre
historisch tief ist wo ist dann die
gefährliche Pandemie frage ich sie jetzt
kann man durch sagen verschobene
Operationen und so weiter ja das ist
aber wenn Sie diese unglaublich
gefährliche Pandemie haben dann müssen
sie trotzdem an an das Limit kommen der
krankenhausbelegung es war nie der Fall
wir hatten zu 13% Unterbelegung
durchgehend und dann muss man doch
irgendwann mal nachdenken wir haben 2020
ein mildes Sterbejahr gehabt und das ist
Fakt und dann muss man doch mal
nachdenken dass das diskriminiert doch
überhaupt keine Toten jeder hat keine
harmlos aber es wird nun mal gestorben
auf intensiv und da muss gucken an an
was wie kann man es verhindern und haben
wir eine besondere Situation und sie war
bei covid 19 nicht gegeben kobit 19 ist
eine Erkrankungen hat eine paar
interessante Aspekte es hängt aber dem
Ursprung zusammen das Virus führt es ja
zu weit aber es war niemals die
außergewöhnliche Bedrohung gewesen das
ist einfach vielleicht auch daran dass
es jetzt einfach darum der Virus auch
ein bisschen mutiert ist dass wir jetzt
haben
also jetzt ist ja was ich halt
verglichen jetzt kann man es vergleichen
mit einer normalen Grippe also schon
seit Omegon was ich halt auch unfair
finde ist ich bin auch gleich fertig
dass man einfach die ganzen
Nebenwirkungen die ganzen Impfschäden
unter den Tisch fallen lässt also so tut
als ob das überhaupt gar keine geht also
das ist entnehmen Wirkung gibt das wird
nicht unter das wird nicht unter den
Tisch geklärt es gibt immer
Pflege bei allen anderen auch bei allen
anderen gibt es Nebenwirkungen
ich glaube dass diese Debatte weder
einen überzeugt der vor einer anderen
Meinung hatte noch umgekehrt es geht
hier um
spielersprüche der eine behauptet dass
der andere das ich persönlich habe viel
mir fehlte Einblick und das Wissen das
wirklich ab beurteilen zu können ich
habe nur höre die Meldungen Florida zum
Beispiel ist es jetzt verboten eminema
Impfstoffe so weiter zu verabreichen
aufgrund von Nebenwirkungen aus der
us-bundestadt Florida dann sagen das
sind ein Trump Leute dann sind Texas
auch ne sag mal so wie sie haben gesagt
politisch
Vorwurf und da muss ich ihnen das sagen
jetzt erworben erhoben worden der
Begriff Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit
Verbrechen gegen den Menschen ist in
Nürnberger Prozess geboren worden als
eine neue Strafrechts Kategorie nach dem
Holocaust und den schlimmen Verbrechen
die geschehen sind während des Zweiten
Weltkrieges durch Deutschland und
deswegen muss ich sie wirklich fragen ob
sie soweit gehen sie müssen sich der
Dimension ihres Vorwurfs und das meine
ich nicht mal unbedingt nur persönlich
voll Bewusstsein wenn sie behaupten hier
sind Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
vorgekommen müssen Sie dies in der
Öffentlichkeit auch ausfechten ich hoffe
Sie sind sich dessen bewusst darf ich
Ihnen zwei Beitrag weiter darf ich Ihnen
zwei Beispiele ja zum Beispiel
der 70-Jährige Mann liegt mit
Herzinfarkt im Krankenhaus hat ein
positiven PCR-Test
ist als isoliert darf nicht besucht
werden seine Ehefrau ist nicht geimpft
und seine Verwandtschaft darf ihn auch
nicht besuchen er muss alleine sterben
das ist ein Verbrechen obwohl das
medizinisch nicht gerechtfertigt ist die
kinderimpfung wir haben wir haben hier
überhaupt grausam wir haben hier also
wir haben hier haben
wir haben
0,0,0 Nutzen zu erwarten für die
kinderimpfung weil die Kinder von
kurwelt überhaupt nicht bedroht sind
aber wir haben glasklare bei Hinweise
wie schwer die Nebenwirkungen sind die
Kinder können wenn es schlimm läuft wir
wissen es nicht die Kinder können ihr
Leben lang darunter leiden aber Kinder
über kinderimpfungen
würden Moment persönlich sagen ich
verklage ich verklage Jens Spahn und ich
verklage auch die restliche
Bundesregierung und im auch noch daran
Lauterbach mit dazu wenn Juristen
interessanten ich bin natürlich Arzt und
kein Jurist nach meinem Rechtsempfinden
wurden Verbrechen begangen aber das
müssen natürlich Juristen feststellen
wenn ich also jetzt Juristen finde sind
eine intellektueller sie müssen noch ein
Grundwissen haben über die Dinge
was bedeutet unterbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit wir wollen das
vergleichen mit dem was passiert wenn
jetzt
Strafgesetzbuch
Beispiel heute meine Sprechstunde heute
ja ein 50-jähriger Mann Kraftfahrer
zweimal beim TG geimpft nach der zweiten
Impfung hat er schon Abend nicht mehr
gespürt ja dann ging es weiter
unerträgliche Schmerzen heute sind seine
Muskulatur zurückgegangen kein Arzt hat
ihn ernst genommen er sagt das kommt von
Dave ich weiß es und ich habe genau
diese Symptomatiken jetzt schon 50 Fach
gehört von Patienten diese
muskelproblematiken Schwächeanfälle
Krämpfe und dergleichen
der wurde da wurde sogar von einem Arzt
gesagt das bilden sie sich ein das sind
Tennisarm müssen wir operieren hat
operiert nichts hat geholfen und war in
der Reha eine Oberärztin hat gesagt
hinter der war so ja ich das kommt von
der Impfung im Bericht stand es nicht
drin was ist das frage ich also
von meinem Arzt geimpft worden damit
sein armsteifelt
ist erstens erstens das
Infektionsschutzgesetz also die ganze
Voraussetzung für die bedingte Zulassung
war nicht gegeben weil die
Außergewöhnlichkeit der Situation gar
nicht da war zweitens die Leute wurden
nicht ausreichend aufgeklärt es wurde
ihnen nicht gesagt sie bedingte
Zulassung es wurde ihnen nicht gesagt
dass es erhebliche sicherheitsbedecken
gibt an der krankenkassenzahlen anhand
der abrechnungsziffern der Krankenhäuser
und so weiter und das ich weiß ob das
vorsätzlich ist ich weiß nur dass es
nicht okay ist und zwar gar nicht okay
also was man auf jeden Fall sagen kann
ist das verschwiegen wurde was in dieser
schadensberichten drin stand und man hat
auch behauptet das gelbe eine sterile
Immunität man hat den Leuten gegenüber
gesagt das wäre nebenwirkungsfreien
jetzt haben wir tote also entschuldigung
das wussten ich würde das gerne an
dieser Stelle jetzt noch mal ein
bisschen einfangen denn ich glaube wir
verrennen uns hier ein bisschen in
diesem Thema und ich glaube wir sind
jetzt alle auch ein bisschen zu
aufgeregt zu schlecht gelaunt vielleicht
sollte man einfach auch mal ein bisschen
mehr lachen sich ein bisschen mehr
freuen und eventuell auch diese ganzen
krisenprobleme einfach mal weglachen